corona beschäftigt uns ja schon eine
ganze weile und was vor allem jetzt im
winter immer wieder gesagt wird ist
bitte bleiben sie wenn immer möglich zu
hause an ihrem wohnort ich kann das ja
ganz gut machen ich kann einfach nach
hause gehen
aber es gibt menschen die haben kein
zuhause obdachlose menschen leben ja auf
der straße und können sich nicht so
einfach zurückziehen eine wohnungslose
menschen sind eine risikogruppe und zwar
eine risikogruppe zu erkranken weil sie
sind häufig chronisch krank multimorbide
das heißt sie haben verschiedene
erkrankungen dann sie haben kein zuhause
wo sie sich isolieren können sie haben
wenig finanzielle mittel und von daher
sind sie besonders gefährdet sich zu
infizieren
es leben in deutschland wohl ungefähr
50.000 menschen auf der straße das ist
aber nur eine schätzung bei obdachlose
menschen werden nicht gezählt
offizielle statistiken zu obdachlosen in
deutschland gibt es nicht
als ob es den staatlichen stellen
peinlich ist dass diese form der armut
überhaupt existiert schreibt die
hilfsorganisation malteser auf ihrer
internetseite
aber natürlich existiert sie nicht erst
seit kuba durch corona hat sich die
situation noch einmal verschärft das
wird ja jetzt auch gerade wieder unter
corona zeiten so deutlich ja das ist wie
ein brennglas wo es soziale
ungerechtigkeit wo die benachteiligung
von menschen noch mal so deutlich wird
ein wohnungslose menschen denkt man dann
ganz am ende wenn irgendwie noch zeit
ist und wenn vielleicht noch ein paar
finanzielle ressourcen zur verfügung
stehen ich bin heute unterwegs um mit
obdachlosen und auch mit menschen die
ihm helfen zu sprechen wie denn die
aktuelle situation ist damit sie
hoffentlich nicht vergessen wird die
vergessene risikogruppe
ich darf heute dr trabert begleiten er
hilft seit 25 jahren menschen die auf
der straße leben
fünfmal pro woche behandelt er sie
gemeinsam mit seinem team heute fährt er
mit seinem arzt mobil durch die stadt
als erstes fahren wir jetzt so einem
kleinen zeltlager
[Musik]
sie meinen patienten momentan
ja in einem zelt im leben
ich weiß nicht ob sie da sind aber wir
schauen immer vorbei und das sind schon
erkrankungen manschette gewöhnliche gar
zum teil auch magen darm erkrankungen
erkrankungen der bauchspeicheldrüse doch
dass das ist schon so ja woher wissen
sie denn wo sie ihren sinn
das sind tipps aus der szene selbst muss
man zudem und dem da liegt da und da das
ist auch eine erfahrung wenn wir unsere
touren machen dass wir da und da jemand
entdecken so an ich gehe dann jetzt da
über die straße und die bleiben gerade
dann hier sehen gleich mit ok natürlich
will nicht jeder gefilmt werden und wir
achten auf die privatsphäre
das ist gesetzlich so vorgeschrieben hat
aber auch etwas mit respekt zu tun
darüber hatte ich auch mit dr trat schon
bevor wir losgefahren sind gesprochen
das thema wird nun respekt dass das ist
natürlich auch das ist für uns alle
wichtig ja das ist ja nichts besonderes
das ist uns allen wichtig dass man uns
so behandelt aber wenn ich dann als
betroffener wohnungsloser man
wohnungslose frau spüre dass ich hier
überhaupt nicht jetzt mehr auf der
agenda stehe dann institution eindruck
ich bin für diese gesellschaft wertlos
nutzlos also schläft die regierung der
in der hinsicht ein bisschen oder
schiebt das so vor sich her
wie kann man das sagen dass das ist eine
gute frage ich frage mich auch sind sie
blind auf diesem auge oder will man gar
nicht so dieses fass aufmachen
ich glaube wird das sehr viele
entscheidungsträger einfach meilenweit
entfernt sind von der lebensrealität der
menschen da würde ich mir wünschen dass
politik muss ich auch mehr diesen
realitäten öffnet und vielleicht auch
mal im arztmobil mitfährt einen dialog
mit betroffenen eintritt um zu erfahren
was bedeutet dass in dieser gesellschaft
sozial benachteiligt zu sein
beim thema obdachlosigkeit passiert also
nicht so viel und politiker gucken da
auch seit jahren immer wieder weg die eu
will jetzt offenbar nicht mehr weggucken
und hat ende november eine resolution
verabschiedet in der das ziel formuliert
ist obdachlosigkeit in der eu bis 2030
beseitigen wie das passieren soll wird
nicht konkret gesagt das kann jedes land
dann für sich entscheiden
ein vorbild dafür könnte finnland sein
da steigen die zahlen der obdachlosen
nämlich nicht sondern sie sinken
seit 1987 sind sie von 18.000 auf
sechseinhalb 1000 gesunken
wie machen die das das prinzip heißt
housing first also zuerst eine wohnung
für die obdachlosen in vielen ländern
ist es genau andersrum
da müssen erst die probleme gelöst
werden also finanzielle probleme
gesundheitliche probleme oder
suchtprobleme zum beispiel und dann gibt
es eine wohnung und in finnland es ist
andersherum für dieses haus im first
programm wurden obdachlosenwohnheim
umgebaut es wurden neue häuser gekauft
neue häuser gebaut also es wurde geld in
die hand genommen und zwar bisher 270
millionen euro
das hört sich viel an aber im vergleich
zu vorher konnte der finnische stadt auf
sparen und zwar 14.000 euro pro
obdachlosen bei nämlich polizeieinsätze
wegfallen gesundheitliche notfälle
fallen weg und es gibt wieder mehr
menschen die arbeit finden
so ein programm wird zum beispiel von
der caritas auch für deutschland
gefordert
das größte problem das sie aber aktuell
sehen ist es gibt zu wenig bezahlbaren
wohnraum die wohnung die aktuellen
deutschland gebaut werden sind oftmals
viel zu teuer und deshalb bleibt
finnland aktuell ein unerreichtes
vorbild
zurück zu unserer tour mit dem arztmobil
bei der ersten station war gerade
niemand auf dem weg zurück treffen wir
günni der schon länger auf der straße
lebt dr trabert macht sich sorgen um
genießen zu töten fuß er selbst sieht
das noch locker genauso steht er auch
zum corona virus was angst dass du dich
an stecken könnte ist spaniens wir aber
ich kann mich ja mit anderen servern
stellte kreuzstraße juli lebt nach dem
motto das leben auf der straße ist hart
und irgendwie kommen wir zurecht
das hört doktor trat häufig mit ihm geht
es zum zweiten stopp der arzt mobil tour
die container der stadt jedes jahr im
winter stellt die stadt mainz solche
container auf damit sich da die
obdachlosen dann in dieser kalten
jahreszeit aufhalten können jetzt in
corona zeiten dürfen anstatt vier
menschen nur drei in einen container
das soll es ein bisschen entzerren aber
wirklich isolieren kann sich da keiner
wir dürfen da drin leider nicht drehen
deswegen warten wir vorne auf der
trabert er sagt allen bescheid dass er
jetzt da ist der erste patient hat
starke rückenschmerzen
während ihnen dr trabert behandelt
unterhalte ich mich draußen mit obert
einem bewohner der container machen sie
sich gedanken jetzt auf der straße noch
zu sein aktuell während des corona virus
jahre spielt natürlich immer eine rolle
mit aber
es ist für mich nicht so brisant also es
kommt nicht so sehr an mich heran also
ich lasse das nicht so sehr an mich
heran
letztendlich also von daher ist es
eigentlich okay so ja die paar
obdachlosen mit denen ich jetzt eben
gesprochen habe die haben alle den
eindruck gemacht dass die korona gar
nicht so beschäftigt und sie sich gar
nicht so die sorgen machen
ich weiß nicht ist das jetzt nur vor der
kamera so gewesen oder meinen sie die
schieben das so von sich weg also
generell habe ich immer wieder
festgestellt man nennt das das
zufriedenheit paradoxon das heißt dass
die eigene situation positiver
eingeschätzt wird als dass sie objektiv
ist um in der situation einfach auch
existieren zu können wenn ich mir dann
doch alle risiken immer wieder
vergegenwärtigen dann dann ersticke ich
in dieser angst ja und von daher ist das
manchmal denke ich auch so eine
bewältigungsstrategie zu sagen naja ist
ja nicht so schlimm ja ich glaube also
wenn wenn wir uns dann mal in ruhe
unterhalten dann spüre ich doch häufig
auch eine angst vor ansteckung und was
dann passiert das ist ziemlich
nachvollziehbar
auf unserer tour geht es weiter zu einer
obdachlosenunterkunft dies schon länger
in mainz gibt die einzige extra
unterkunft dies aufgrund der pandemie
gibt liegt in einem mainzer vorort
housing area heißt sie 25 einzelzimmer
die nicht für alle obdachlose reichen
glauben sie denn dass sie ihre
mitarbeiter die stadt dass sie
ausreichend vorbereitet sind auf viel
größere krise in dieser obdachlosen
struktur in sachen corona also ich
glaube nicht wirklich dass man das so
auf der agenda hat
ich glaube wenn wenn jetzt wirklich
worst case in so eine einrichtung ein
fall positiv getestet wird dann
befürchte ich dass wir große probleme
bekommen werden
unser team denke ich wir sind schon gut
aufgestellt wir haben genaue
vorgehensweise aber es steht und fällt
mit wohnraum
und es steht und fällt dann auch mit
einer versorgung dieser menschen und da
hoffe ich dass wir nicht in so eine
situation hinein städtern dr trabert tut
was er kann damit das nicht passiert und
so viele menschen wie möglich
rechtzeitig unterkommen gerade jetzt
während des winters gestern ganze nacht
habe ich fast ein bisschen geschlafen
wegen mein füße sie waren ganz ganz heiß
kalt ich weiß nicht warum aber ja ich
mache sorge mehr ja- und machen sie sich
auch sorgen wegen corona natürlich hier
ja blut lebt erst seit anderthalb
monaten auf der straße dr trabert trifft
ihn heute zum ersten mal wie ich mir das
aus
und ich versuche das jetzt zeitnah zu
regeln dass sie in die housing area in
ein zimmer dort über den winter kommen
heute geht es häufig gar nicht um
medizinischen rat
es ist kalt es ist winter es geht um
schlafsäcke isomatten und
unterbringungen da habe ich sie kurz was
fragen
jetzt habe ich herausgehört sie ziehen
in diese neue obdachlosenunterkunft ja
das hat mir empfohlen wollte ich wurde
angegriffen macht mein auge ist jetzt
wieder besser aber dann sieht's nach ja
wo sie schlafen sie aktuell offene
toilette in der nähe da wo ich mir also
geld mache und wie geht es ihm psychisch
so machen sie sich sorgen machen sie
sich gedanken
ich kriege eigentlich mal auge war nicht
mehr richtig sehe ich hier auf ich höre
auf jedes geräusch kann ich mir
vorstellen
ein anderes thema jetzt aktuell corona
krise machen sie sich dann sorgen dass
die sich anstecken könnten gar nicht
wenn man einmal auf der straße ist dann
hat man ein dickes fell
also von daher habe ich keine angst
davor
ich war okay dass ich nachts angegriffen
werde im schlaf damit habe ich auch nie
gerechnet
aber ganz ehrlich man hat ein dickes
fell inzwischen ein dickes fell von dem
viele hoffen dass es sie schützt auch
vor dem corona virus aber das ist nicht
so präsent was sie spüren ist die kälte
viel zu klären für sie hier unterwegs
ja das waren jetzt schon drei leute die
in diese neue unterkunft gern
ja ich meine jetzt sind wir ja auch
gerade am anfang ja das ist noch nicht
so bekannt und jetzt ist es aber wichtig
dass wir das kommunizieren und dass wir
das dann organisieren und realisieren ja
weil wenn es jetzt kälter wird dann ist
das ist es einfach absolut gefährlich
weiter auf der straße zu sein
trotz der hilfen erfrieren jedes jahr
obdachlose menschen
auch hier gibt es keine statistik wie
viele es tatsächlich sind
einen tag nach unserer arztmobil tour
wurde in mainz eine 72 jährige frau tot
in ihrem zelt gefunden
sie ist dort wohl erfroren wir sind
jetzt zwei stunden unterwegs und ich
muss ehrlich zugeben
obwohl ich in meinem leben wir nicht so
viele obdachlose auf wie ich heute mit
dr trabert sehe also man läuft da oft
vorbei und nimmt es nicht mal muss ich
zugeben ich nehme es nicht war doktor
trabert kennt die meisten obdachlosen in
mainz ihn zum beispiel trifft er nur im
winter an
wir halten abstand der man schämt sich
wohl häufig für seine situation und
möchte nicht auffallen
vor allem möchte auch niemandem zur last
fallen
dr trabert bemüht sich zu helfen und
heute nimmt der mann die hilfe auch an
schlafsack und isomatte was mir eben
auch immer wichtig ist die menschen so
zu akzeptieren wie sie sind also jetzt
nicht zu fordern sie müssen doch
irgendwo eine unterkunft sie müssen doch
das und das sondern angebote machen
sie werden angenommen oder nicht
angenommen und einfach da sein aber
nicht mit forderungen versehen
wie können sie dann hier schlafen und
sie müssen da und da hin dass das machen
wir nicht jeder darf so sein wie er ist
wir bieten etwas an und die entscheidung
liegt bei den betroffenen
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht immer so
leicht ich habe heute selbst gemerkt
dass ich innerlich manchmal direkt
anpacken wollte die schicksale die ich
heute erlebt habe die mit teilweise
recht nahe
ich merke nach diesen drei stunden schon
dass es ganz schön an meinen kräften
gezehrt hat dass ich für mich ganz schön
schlapp wie geht es ihnen damit
gut ich ich hab ja so ein bisschen
routine jetzt aber routine darf nicht
bedeuten nicht mehr sensibel zu sein und
aufmerksam zu sein und sie haben
natürlich vollkommen recht
es erfordert eine sehr hohe
konzentration also immer präsent zu sein
immer auch zuzuhören
natürlich auch mal zu sagen so jetzt
geht es weiter
auch grenzen zu setzen aber doch einfach
dazu seien voll konzentriert da zu sein
das stimmt schon ich bin jetzt auch dann
dann mühte und es ist auch eine
müdigkeit wissen sie die die nicht einen
leer macht sondern die einem das gefühl
oder mir das gefühl gibt das war gut
wird das war stimmig und du hast etwas
sinnvolles getan
ich konnte heute so ein bisschen ihnen
folgen und bei ihnen dabei sein aber ich
habe ja nicht wirklich mit angepackt und
ich bin ja auch kein arzt ich kann nicht
so tolle sachen machen wie sie was
würden sie denn so einer privatperson
mitnehmen wenn sie irgendwas machen
möchte was kann man dann vielleicht auch
im kleinen für obdachlose tun also dass
das eine was mir immer wichtig ist
investieren sie das teuerste was sie
haben das wertvollste was sie haben und
dass es zeit einfach mal stehen zu
bleiben wenn jemand am straßenrand sitzt
mit ihm in einen dialog einzutreten wenn
er das möchte
und dann auch zu fragen kann ich etwas
für sie tun hätten sie gern im café eine
brezel ein café stück oder soja das
nicht bitte einfach was kaufen aber auch
da gilt die menschen fragen ja und dass
das macht viel aus weil dann wird
derjenige als mensch wahrgenommen und
das hat sie wieder viel mit respekt und
mit würde zu tun
ansonsten ist es mir immer wichtig sich
zu engagieren um strukturelle
benachteiligungen zu diskutieren
anzugehen und zu überlegen wie kann ich
den menschen auf der straße helfen
[Musik]
wie geht ihr mit obdachlosen um hälfte
ihn vielleicht schon bereitet euch
irgendwas schwierigkeiten schreibt es
uns in die kommentare
ansonsten haben wir hier auch noch
andere videos für euch